[Music]
[Applause]
there
mac jones the alabama quarterback kind
enough to join us on the program
i didn't realize this it's michael
mccorkle
mac jones so when did we go from michael
to mac jones um really just early on
like in lower school i think my teacher
was a substitute teacher
and she called out michael jones and i
kind of like looked around
and then sure enough i was like oh just
call me back so it just stuck from there
i guess
who calls you michael uh really nobody
honestly like my parents are not
like they wouldn't say hey michael if
they're mad at me so it's always been
mac
and i guess just my legal name is
michael so how do you know when uh coach
saban's mad at you
usually he just kind of says like hey
hey mac hey mac and then i know he's
coming up to me to talk to me
and usually something follows with the
lesson of what he's trying to teach me
so
i mean it happens and he obviously
coaches me hard so
i enjoy that what if you get a look but
no words
what's that mean words are coming
so so even if you get a look you know
words are eventually coming
yeah i just it'll take a second he'll
just kind of be like and then maybe
you know tell me tell me what he wants
to say after he looks at me for a couple
seconds
what's your favorite sabin story
um i don't know if i have a great like
one i can tell on here well i okay
josh jacobs came on last year
and said that coach saban likes to use
the expression dee's nuts
yeah okay so we already got that one and
then i did ask coach saban and then he
did verify that yes he has been known to
say
how about the deez nuts so we've already
established that mac
so we can go wherever you want to go
with coach saban and it feels like look
you're a heisman candidate i mean you're
okay all right
you won't get in trouble for this i'll
vouch for you i don't know about that
but
okay um yeah i mean we just
we have fun out there and and talk a
little smack to each other but
i don't want to get into too many
details wait you talk smack back to
coach
what do you say you you talk smack back
to coach saban
yeah i mean maybe he'll like say out the
coverage in like a couple of our drills
and i'm like oh cover two coach and he's
like yeah but you still can't beat it or
something like that
because i know most of the defense is
called so i like to listen
and i'll be like oh is that two-man
coach is that cover seven and
we kind of just mess around in that way
how did you end up at alabama
um really just in the recruiting process
um coach saban
you know invited me to come up to camp
and i'd never really been to alabama and
my family
my dad actually drove pretty much
overnight to get me a chance to
throw in front of the coaches at a camp
and i just kind of fell in love with
coach saban
and his process and talking with him you
know being up here at that camp
really just sold me on alabama yeah but
weren't you in a camp
where tua was there
and you knew tua was going to alabama
but you still
decided that you were going like you
didn't see something that you said i
can't compete with
with tua because if he's going to be the
star
you know sometimes you look at somebody
to go uh maybe i should go to kentucky
instead yeah um i mean really just came
back to just
to focus on how can i get better and
what school will give me the best chance
to improve
so i didn't really even look at it like
that until i was obviously
committed before me and i committed
after tua and i understood what type of
player two it was
but at the end of the day i just like i
said coach saban
kind of just sold me on how he had a
plan for me to get better
and develop as a in the weight room in
the film room all that stuff and
when you're coming here and playing
against the practicing against the best
players and
in the whole country then you're going
to get better and i knew eventually
at some point i was going to get a shot
so i just had to be prepared for that
moment
yeah but mack if i told you three years
ago you're going to be a heisman
finalist what would you have said
um i don't really know i just try and
prepare
every day for that moment and i grew up
watching a bunch of great quarterbacks
and
um to be in the talks of that is really
awesome but
at the end of the day like i always say
this it's more about
my teammates and just winning the game
and all that stuff will take care of
itself because
if you focus on the wrong things um and
results then
you're not going to end up where you
want to be you grew up in florida right
yes okay so give me the good
quarterbacks that you saw
probably not in florida so who were you
professionally who were you watching and
and saying that that you know that's
somebody i want to
model my game after yeah i mean i like
watching all nfl football but i've
always liked watching like tom brady
um or aaron rodgers peyton manning
people like that growing up
but really i don't have like a favorite
favorite quarterback or anything like
that and
obviously i was in florida like you said
so i was a big tebow fan
while he was in college so just watching
him play was really cool too
have you met tebow uh yeah we've talked
before
how did that go it's it's good i mean i
wish i could talk to him more and i'm
sure this season
hopefully i'll be able to talk to him at
one of these uh media things or
something but
um like i said i saw him playing high
school and
saw him in college and now obviously
he's doing great things
how many how many touchdowns do you
think i could throw in a game
with your with your wide receivers okay
when everybody's healthy
yeah okay i mean let's just be honest
mac i i know you've had a great year but
um yeah i mean i'm looking at the guys
you're throwing to
yeah i i gotta believe i could get maybe
one or two touchdowns in a game oh
easily
like like again let's say i'm facing ole
miss or mississippi state like i should
be able to get one or two right
yeah i mean i mean our guys are are
making plays and they're getting open so
i'd assume
if you can throw it past 10 yards or at
least give them a chance
oh i can sling it i can give you
probably 50 yards if i need to
there you go and those guys are wide
open too i mean yeah
they are wide open i mean that's that's
their job and you know it's
it is hard to hit wide open receivers
wait a minute
okay hold on it's hard to hit wide open
receivers yeah
okay yeah explain um so
i'm i'm sure you've heard this before
but it's the hardest catch to make for
sure because
you know you're wide open you get a
little more like antsy and things like
that
and honestly when someone's getting
covered it's like
more of a challenge to put it in the
right spot but at the same time there's
all that feel that you can miss and it's
just one guy you're looking at
so i mean if there's there's a good
amount of margin for error
like popular to what people would
probably think devante smith's pretty
good there mac
yeah he's pretty good like does he ever
amaze you
oh yeah yeah he like not only with the
plays he makes but like sometimes he'll
he'll point out the blitzes on the
defense and that that's something that
really impresses me about smitty
whether that's in practice or even in
the games be like hey
safety safety blitz right here
so that's pretty impressive for a
receiver to be able to tell me
yeah and he's you know there are times
when he it feels like he's the best
player on the field
that game against lsu i mean it just
felt like he was the best player out
there
all right he definitely is like i say
this all the time he's
one of the best players in the country
and um he works really hard and
he's been doing that for the past four
years at alabama and
his highlight reel is insane and i just
love throwing him the ball because
he'll if it's one-on-one he'll make the
play and he just has a lot of faith in
me so
i appreciate him for that how much did
the smack talk
from lsu the previous year factor in
this past weekend against lsu um yeah a
little bit i mean we definitely
addressed it
but at the same time it was a new year
and
like we obviously didn't feel great we
lost the game um you know a close game
last year but
we definitely addressed that in our
player only meeting about how we just
wanted to go out there and
and get a chance to show show lsu what
the new team looked like
and we definitely played really well as
a team so we were excited about that
can you hear coach oh during a game
no i couldn't even i couldn't hear him
oh okay yeah with that voice i thought
that you might be able to uh to hear him
no uh what have you graduated
yeah so i already um graduated last year
for my undergrad in communication
studies and then
i'm actually graduating um this saturday
again with my master's in sport
hospitality
what do you want to do um that's a great
question
i really don't know like people always
ask me that but maybe
i don't know become like a sports
broadcaster just something around sports
because i love sports a lot
and um you know i just want to play as
long as i can because
that's always just been a part of my
life
but how did you learn to speak chinese
so i took that that class in um in high
school
and we just started my freshman year i
guess some me and some of my buddies
um we just kind of spoke it with our our
teacher and she taught us everything we
knew
and i kind of lost a lot of it but i'm
getting i'm getting it back i guess i
have to study up on it
you don't want to lose that you you want
to be able to speak a couple
how do you say roll tide in mandarin
chinese
um uh usually they just like
they'll use like slang words but um i
mean i can say like i play football
alabama
okay or gone lancio zai alabama
so like that would be like i play
football alabama yeah you need roll tide
you need real time i'll text my teacher
and ask her do you do you do audibles
like do you have fun names for audibles
um not really so you don't get to go to
line of scrimmage and say
yell out something that would be funny
or you know we see the pro quarterbacks
doing this
yeah a little bit i mean most of the
times when we have when we say something
it actually means something for like the
offensive line or the receiver so
there's not
a lot of dummy um i guess verbal
things that i can do but there's some
dummy signals and things like that
that we use and a lot of times it's just
the play is called
and i can check it or coach sark our
offensive coordinator will
look with me and we'll figure out what
play we want to get next
um you got arkansas coming up
yes you can't mail it in against
arkansas
yeah those guys they're playing a lot
better they are
and like we said you know in our team
meeting they've lost a bunch of games
but
by a very small margin and their record
really doesn't show how good of a team
they are
mac last uh last weekend 385 yards four
touchdowns on the season 27 touchdowns
three interceptions just over uh 3 000
yards
it'll be fun here uh big chase there uh
with you and kyle trask i don't know if
anybody else is going to factor in what
do you do better than kyle trask
i don't think i do anything really
different or better than kyle
i actually like really liked watching
kyle i actually told him last year
you know when we're watching film on
teams a lot of times florida was the
team
that we were watching the defense
against and i just like watching kyle
play and i actually texted him
or shot him an instagram message and
just told him that i really enjoyed
how he plays football and how he plays
quarterback and you can tell he's just
a really good player and he's doing a
great job down there you've got to do
better than that talking smack i mean
come on you can't
think come on mac come on you gotta say
something no all right
yeah hopefully uh you'll uh let your
play do all the talking when you guys uh
go head to head there but
congrats on the season and uh we
appreciate your time thank you mac
okay thank you have a nice day that's uh
mac jones
don't call him michael it's mac jones